Hey look Jordan turns it down there
nothing you buy
very good
Oh
Marie
grace hi
well you appeared to be done on the one
side and we thought
apologize Paloma Faith I'm so sorry
are you getting her shoot that's one
hell of a shoot
give it to our Philippi I just love it
Lord Grantham's a freak Oh blow blow
effects before you get eaten and that
singles happen Feb 23rd it is that new
album is on that it's March the Templar
called a perfect contradiction which I
think these three gentlemen definitely
fitted and it's all it's all had up
tempo lease of its Dancy stuff it's kind
of upbeat just disco and fun and it's
like if it's all gone to then let's
just have a dance yes yeah can you say
bronze a over here yeah
tyranny began well then the goodness
dense and and the ethanol that you
haven't met the guys on the couch before
have you
no people you've got to know them very
quickly I would say well you have met
George Clooney I have met George Clooney
oh I was a open the BAFTAs last year
actually it's great all right he said
that he'd noticed that I kept going to
the toilet I was like why haven't you
been to the toilet like all night he had
been to the toilet and um he told me he
had a colostomy bag on set he went to
the toilet much with you my he must have
really trusted yeah
I don't have to know him for like a
decade before you listen we're going to
go to the red chair just where we go see
who's there who's up who's up hello hi
hi for once you're quite glad you're the
distance aren't you Rebecca this is
Rebecca and where you from Rebecca New
Zealand please surprise me can I just
ask you really quickly so this is a
situation where we're allowed to one of
us pulls this lever
she flips yeah okay
experiment yeah okay that was her I hope
her story wasn't very good I'm imagining
it wasn't so if you don't like her story
you pulled this lever is really real
that was really real I was a human being
does he was rehearsed you know well cut
in or in some way that was really yeah
that just happened she went you know
this yeah I didn't do it he did it I
didn't do it did you grew up in a forest
or something that's this won't
get down in one let's see what you got
here's such a rock and roll star
wait ladies and gentlemen her rehab is
taking that's right let's try someone
else in the red chair okay quick let's
even get a story hello nice lady what's
your name
Jessica Jessica conclude Quinn here
Jessica bye then
she's so sweet and she's French
she's adorable I don't think she's
French she said did she say like Panem
she said pardon
she's paused
you want to know okay can you get me
over go in the chair okay go you go and
do that again okay where's the chair it
took all of that man their follow up
following us there you go okay but but
hurry we've got homes to go to
okay by the way this is the best time
I've ever had I'm a talk show
all right
yeah I think it's the champagne off the
hose okay who's up next hi We're Sussex
are you hi I just like to say that I
think Matt Damon is really amazing in
the fourth born with the two back I
think just natural nature that's one of
my favorite 'back a moment it's just
that part of that makes a deeper and I
said that I do my own makeup but I can
tell you and real diva would never do
her own makeup that part is it also
ridiculous